Democrats have another reason to be
worried about 2020 president Trump's
urging support among African Americans
the news has already got liberals
nervous including radio host Charlamagne
tha God hears his ominous warning for
black Trump supporters quote it's not
worth it I don't think that we have
gotten to the point in our society where
we can take chances on a president or
maybe putting money in our pockets but
rolling back all our other social civil
rights I don't care how rich you are if
you don't have civil rights what's the
point who wants to be a [ __ ] rich slave
never mind that Trump signed criminal
justice reform into law restored funding
for religious historically black
colleges joining me now is horace cooper
co-chairman of project 21 and author of
the book how Trump is making black
America great again
along with Leo Tyrell civil rights
attorney horace what what's your
reaction to liberals who say trump's
stripping black americans of their civil
rights i laughed when i heard that
people really think if given a choice to
be prosperous to be successful or even
rich they would say no no i want to make
sure that there are laws on the books so
that a landlord can't say to a tenant
that you're ashy when you think there he
that's supposed to be the priority for
black america or any group in america
over success and prosperity get real if
that's the plan plan to be very sad on
Election Day next November okay Leo I
need your reaction to this I'm gonna
play this to you this is a panel of
african-american voters on Comedy
Central of all places on The Daily Show
they tried to mock some of these voters
but watch what they discovered Chris who
do you think this understands the needs
of the black voter Donald Trump some of
the stuff I've heard he's already doing
it's like prison reform he's been
hanging around black people as long as I
can remember they loved him til he ran
for president as a Republican Trump was
the man how many of you all still think
Trump will win in 2020
from 2020 baby leo your reaction for
them raised their hands everybody about
one said they thought Trump was going to
win my reaction is very simple that's a
small percentage of African Americans I
hate hey here's the newsflash less than
9% of african-americans voted for Trump
in 2016 it's gonna get less but let me
go back to what Horace said so everyone
understands is not true it is true and
I'll bet you under double digits for
blacks voting for Trump that's a fact
you know that but I'll take I'll
challenge you I rather have dignity and
equality instead of being a second-class
citizen tell me this Horace why do our
earnings as blacks let me answer you ask
you that why do our earnings that's
black or less than white why do we have
less wealth and whites why do we have an
agreement
why don't we answer that form okay let
me give let me give you dignity dignity
is when your income starts to advance
and in fact advances faster than any
other racial group in America that's
what happened in the last three years
when your employment rate exceeds the
expansion rate exceeds that of every
other group in fact the march on
Washington that Martin Luther King spoke
at say no it's not change the subject
jobs dignity comes from having Americans
say they see I'm throwing a yellow flag
guys give me one second here because I
want to pick up on something Leo said
Leo said and he's right eight percent of
African Americans vote well this is what
you're right about not everything eight
percent of African Americans voted for
Trump in 2016 however a new Emerson poll
finds that Trump enjoys a thirty four
point five percent approval rating among
African Americans now that's up from 17
point eight percent last month what's
happening here Leo if look this is
dangerous territory for the Democrats
isn't it
massive distinction between approval and
actually who you're gonna vote for as
far as voting for Trump is totally
distinguishable from approval rating and
what I'm telling you right now he will
not give more than eight or nine percent
in this upcoming election but let me
just simply say this I don't want any
job I don't want a job I want the same
job anybody regardless of race coloring
and or sex and what horse didn't do is
he didn't answer my question
blacks have only one okay wait I'm
asking the questions leo
horse this is what I want to ask you
that thirty four point five percent if
the the reports show that if the
Democrats can't secure 85 to 90% of the
african-american vote national elections
over for them if the president could
peel away thirty four percent or even
twenty percent he wins how real how much
of a reality do you believe that is the
possibility of political atom bomb if
you start to see the numbers that we
actually saw in Georgia and in Florida
and in Texas where blacks ended up being
the deciding vote for who ended up
winning the state race statewide races
across three states and the reason in
this request is black Americans are
interested I by Jennifer Boulder to you
if he's over tempers he'll i buy dinner
if you don't we're going up we're going
to Ruth's Chris okay I'm holding you
both to this and you're gonna take me
with you very likely to win in America
you've got to appeal with a real winning
agenda that includes jobs well yes or
the question wants that and there's only
Donald Trump doing it now if the other
side doesn't do it you could end up
seeing 12 10 percent or even an 18
percent okay dinner for that all right I
got it
Ruth's Chris I'm making the reservation
and Thank You Ruth for tell originally
okay finally chance I want your reaction
to this Jennifer Lopez JLo will be
performing along with Colombian
superstar Shakira at the Super Bowl
halftime show
this being Super Bowl and in football
season she told the LA Times quote it
super-important for two Latino women to
be headlining the Superbowl especially
right now in Trump's America did we need
JLo to remind us that there are Latinos
in America and isn't this politicizing
the last uniting force in American life
football horse very quickly ten seconds
this identity politics is actually
hurting the left and progressives and
her actions just fulfill that more and
more of us are saying we're just people
we want to watch football we want to
enjoy Thanksgiving don't divide us into
these subsets the Oh Bravo Bravo for JLo
because you know what this president who
has a problem with Hispanic judges
Charlotte Ville she needs to make sure
that we're not forgotten of all people
of color
Bravo JLo well I think if she's gonna
stand up and be the representative of
Latinas you know she's in a movie
hustlers where she's playing a stripper
right now I liked her better when you
know she was in angel eyes so hoarsely
Oh
Happy Thanksgiving thanks for being here
happy thing